now developer tools can also be a really
great help to you during the code test
refine routine you're able to test
things on the fly and see how it affects
your page without actually changing the
HTML and CSS files so for example of
with a header one here I can easily
change the font size to make it bigger
or smaller I can change the font family
say to Arial I can also change the
background colors of things so for
example say I might not have the
hexadecimal color from the designer but
I just want to use this slider and find
something that looks pretty close you
can also click over to the sources tab
and see the code in the same place and
then also remember that you can reset
any changes by just clicking the refresh
button so go ahead and play around a bit
with dev tools and see what you can
change and then let me know just how
cool is it to play with dev tools let me
know on a scale from 1 to 10 with 1
being a total snoozefest and 10 being
totally awesome personally I hope you
choose 10